Benjamin Franklin is well known as one of
the Founding Fathers of America.
But there was another side to this renowned
statesman.
He was a polymath.
Someone who has in-depth knowledge of numerous
subjects.
Franklin was a writer, publisher, scientist,
and inventor who continually reinvented himself.
Benjamin Franklin was born in Boston, Massachusetts
on January 17, 1706 to candle maker Josiah
Franklin and his second wife Abiah Folger.
He was their eighth child and final son.
He also had seven half-siblings from his father’s
first marriage.
At the time of his birth, Boston was already
a thriving seaport: filled with sailors, merchants,
preachers, and prostitutes.
Growing up next to the Charles River, he enjoyed
swimming, and early on the inventor in him
tinkered with ways to glide through the water
more quickly.
He made his own version of fins - his were
two wooden hand paddles.
When Franklin was six, his family moved from
a tiny two-bedroom house to a larger home
in the heart of Boston.
This allowed his father to entertain interesting
dinner guests which Benjamin later remarked
helped “...to improve the minds of his children.”
As for his formal education, Franklin didn’t
have much.
His father only had enough money to send him
to school for two years.
Squashing the expectation of his son going
to Harvard in the hopes of eventually joining
the clergy.
Benjamin’s formal education ended when he
was just ten years old.
Some wonder whether he would have been as
great a scientist as Sir Isaac Newton if he
had received more education.
But what Franklin lacked in formal schooling
he made up for with his passion for reading.
He even stopped eating meat and became a vegetarian
in part so he could save to buy more books!
His love of reading and writing flourished
further when he worked at his brother James’
printing shop as an apprentice.
He even got a chance to publish his own articles
for his brother’s newspaper, one of the
first in America, under the pseudonym “Mrs.
Silence Dogood”.
When he was 17 years old, Franklin left Boston
for New York hoping to break out on his own
and find work as a printer but he didn’t
have any luck.
So he went further south to Philadelphia - which
was then the largest city in America.
He worked in several printer shops around
town, and later for a Philadelphia merchant.
By that time, Benjamin was tall, muscular,
comfortable with any company he kept, and
very charming.
He boarded at the Read family home and fell
in love with 15-year-old Deborah Read. (1723)
Deborah’s mother refused to allow their
marriage because he didn’t have a penny
to his name.
He continued courting Deborah and years later,
they entered into a common-law marriage, and
she ended up raising his illegitimate son
William whom he had with an unknown woman.
Deborah and Benjamin had two other children,
a son named Francis who died of smallpox at
the age of four and a daughter named Sarah.
Franklin spent his twenties helping to improve
the community in Philadelphia.
He formed the “Junto”, a club consisting
of young men from diverse backgrounds that
met on Friday evenings to discuss morals,
politics, philosophy, and science.
They’d discuss questions like: Have you
lately observed any encroachment on the just
liberties of the people?
The Junto meetings were modeled off English
coffeehouses which Franklin knew well, having
worked in a printing shop in London for a
time.
Members loved to read and decided to pool
their money to buy books that everyone could
take their turn enjoying.
They created America’s first lending library,
the Library Company of Philadelphia.
Franklin later became the publisher of The
Pennsylvania Gazette which served as a voice
of opposition to British colonial rule.
Not only did he print the paper, he often
contributed to it.
Like this political cartoon depicting a snake
in pieces called “Join or Die” that was
meant to rally the American colonies together.
Each piece of the snake represented a colony.
There were 13 colonies yet only 8 pieces of
the snack because he grouped some colonies
together.
He also used his newspaper to write about
his inventions including his famous experiments
with electricity.
With the help of his son William, he attached
a wire to the top of a kite which picked up
an electric charge from thunderstorms and
conducted electricity all the way down the
wet kite string.
This led to his invention of the lightning
rod, which protects houses from lightning
when it carries the electric charge harmlessly
to the ground without burning the house down.
Franklin’s ground-breaking work on electricity
made him famous.
That name recognition would come in handy
as he was tasked with convincing the French
to support American independence.
He spent several years stationed near Paris
as America’s first diplomat.
His popularity and diplomatic skills apparently
paid off. France sent troops and supplies
to aid the colonies during the revolutionary
war and formally recognized the U.S. as a
sovereign nation.
Franklin was appointed postmaster general
during the war and in that role, was responsible
for making sure mail was delivered as quickly
as possible by horseback.
This was the crucial line of communication
that held the 13 colonies together.
Despite all the hats he wore, Franklin somehow
found time to devise inventions throughout
his life.
He created bifocal glasses which have two
halves: the upper for distance, the lower
for reading.
The Franklin stove was a metal-lined fireplace
that provided more heat and less smoke than
the open fireplaces used at the time.
One of his more unusual inventions was his
beloved glass armonica.
He worked with a glassblower to create the
musical instrument inspired by musicians who
passed their fingers around the brims of glasses
filled with water.
It was very popular during his time. Mozart
even composed music for it.
If inventing weren’t enough, he also had
a major influence on the science of demography
or studies of the population.
He took notes on population growth and realized
the American population was the fastest-growing
on Earth and would surpass that of England
in a century.
His writing on the subject was not without
controversy.
In an essay, he wrote: “Why increase the
sons of Africa, by planting them in America,
where we have so fair an opportunity, by excluding
all blacks and tawnys, of increasing the lovely
white and red? But perhaps I am partial to
the complexion of my country, for such kind
of partiality is natural to mankind.”
Like many of his time, Franklin owned slaves
and viewed them as inferior to white Europeans.
But in his later years, he became a vocal
proponent of abolishing slavery.
He also didn’t hold other groups in high
regard. When there was an increase in German
immigrants to America, he feared it would
bring down the country as a whole.
As the population grew, Franklin wrote about
the importance of improving farming practices
to meet the booming demand for food.
When he retired from the printing business,
he bought a 300-acre farm in nearby New Jersey.
It became his experimental station where he
carried out projects in drainage, crop rotation,
and fertilization.
Looks like the Founding Father was now a Founding
Foodie!
He also introduced many international foods
and plants to America such as Swiss Barley,
Scotch kale, Chinese rhubarb, and silk.
He was exposed to international goods thanks
to the time he spent in London on diplomatic
missions.
He made many trips there from the 1750s to
the 1770s but would later sever ties to support
the American revolution.
In fact, he had a falling out with his son
William who remained loyal to Britain. Franklin
never forgave his son for “taking up Arms
against me.”
Franklin was part of a Committee that drafted
the Declaration of Independence which explained
why the 13 colonies regarded themselves as
independent and no longer under British rule.
He is the only person to sign all three major
documents that established the United States
as an independent nation: the Declaration
of Independence, the Treaty of Paris, and
the United States Constitution.
After the Constitution was ratified in 1788,
Franklin wrote to a scientist friend in France
and gave us one of the most famous sayings:
“Our new Constitution is now established,
everything seems to promise it will be durable;
but, in this world, nothing is certain except
death and taxes.”
Throughout his middle and later years, Franklin
was obese and suffered many health problems.
He had a long history of lung disease and
gout - a form of inflammatory arthritis that
results in red and swollen joints.
On April 17, 1790, Franklin died at his home
in Philadelphia when an abscess in his lungs
suddenly burst.
He was 84 years old.
It’s estimated 20,000 people attended his
funeral - nearly the entire population of
Philadelphia at the time.
Today, every year, tens of thousands of visitors
toss pennies at Franklin’s gravestone for
good luck, a nod to a famous saying attributed
to him: "a penny saved, is a penny earned”.
Though apparently, he never actually said
this.
He did once write: "Remember that time is
money.”
Without a doubt, Benjamin Franklin used his
time wisely.
If you’d like to hone your skills just like
Franklin did, and who knows, become a polymath
yourself, there’s a great and interactive
way to learn.
Brilliant is an amazing tool for brushing
up on your science, technology, engineering,
and math skills.
It almost doesn’t even feel like learning
because you’re having fun while solving
interactive problems.
Their Everyday Math course helps you see fractions,
percentages, and geometry in a new light.
My personal favorite is the Logic course which
helps improve your critical thinking skills.
If you ever get stuck, there are hints to
help you out, and explanations if you get
the incorrect answer.
There are no tests on Brilliant and you can
work at your own pace.
To get started for FREE, visit to brilliant.org/newsthink
or click on the link in my description or
pinned comment. And the first 200 of you will
get 20% off Brilliant's annual premium subscription
which unlocks all of the courses.
Thanks for watching. For Newsthink, I’m
Cindy Pom